oui c'est dans ce contexte que les
principales puissances de l'otan ont
décidé hier lors d'une réunion par
visioconférence de renforcer la pression
sur le kremlin les américains qui ont
également confirmé un sans préciser les
contours que des pièces détachées des
avions de chasse avait été livré à
l'ukraine ces derniers jours donc c'est
donc il réfléchit également un sixième
train de sanctions contre moscou alors
on va s'intéresser justement à à ces
sanctions sont elles au moins efficace
c'est l'objet de notre décryptage du
jour
décryptage avec vous ali laïdi a
toujours allié alors deux mois après
l'invasion de l'ukraine par la russie
les sanctions économiques occidentales
fonctionne-t-elle a rappelé nous d'abord
peut-être le contenu de ce qui a déjà
été décidé annoncé un bon faut dire tout
de suite que c'est historique vraiment
on n'a jamais vu un tel montant de
sanctions at-elle niveau de sanctions
économiques contre un pays qui plus est
un pays qui entre le onzième ou douzième
place en termes du pib mondial faut
préciser également que une grande partie
de cette fonction existe depuis 2014
l'annexion de la crimée et c'est
qu'elles sont en ce qui concerne l'union
européenne et washington prorogé à
chaque fois de six mois ben il ya en
gros gel des avoirs de 1091 personnes et
80 entité il ya des mesures
diplomatiques des restrictions aux
médias on a vu la disparition de russia
today de spoutnik en europe et
évidemment des restrictions que de
coopération économique sur plan purement
économique on l'a vu exclusion du
système financier interdiction de
commercer baisse des achats drastiques
en ce qui concerne le pétrole un peu
moins le gaz mais surtout le fer l'acier
le bois le charbon
limitation d'accès aux marchés des
capitaux en europe et aux états unis des
restrictions très fortes sur la banque
centrale russe la fermeture très
importante de l'espace aérien de l'union
européenne et puis évidemment le refus
de vendre des biens technologiques à la
russie ça fait déjà cinq 35 sion daté et
on est déjà en train de parler de
finaliser un septième train de sanctions
oui on sent qu en ce moment bruxelles et
washington discutent sur un sixième
train de sanctions qui portera sur quoi
alors peut-être viserait plus
particulièrement la banque d'albert
banques qui représentent quand même 37%
du secteur bancaire russe qu'il n'était
pas dans les premières sanctions donc là
ça sera encore une frappe assez durs
contre le système bancaire russe mais
plus largement l'enjeu je pense qu'on
discute vraiment sur le pétrole et sur
le gaz mais on sait très bien que c'est
à double tranchant que plus les
européens particulier on rompt loin irin
- contre le gaz et le pétrole russe plus
il y aura un retour de bâton pour faire
du coup sanctions d'ambérieu roulera
compris qui tendent à s'accentuer dans
les semaines qui arrivent ça fonctionne
nous ça ne fonctionne pas donc là ça ne
fonctionne pas très clairement il n'y a
pas de cessez le feu il y a les troupes
russes ne sont pas revenus dans dans
leurs cases elle change caserne
changement de stratégie russe
souvenez-vous toute l'ukraine maintenant
sera pas uniquement son combat ce n'est
pas du tout aux sanctions c'est tout
simplement dû à des revers des échecs
militaires sur le terrain donc le
président poutine s'est exprimé il ya
quelques jours en disant que ça ne
faisait rien pratiquement une sanction
et que c'était plutôt un retour de bâton
contre les oxydants que sa frappe est
plutôt les autres les occidentaux bon
quand même le rouble a perdu 50% de sa
valeur dès les premiers jours à la suite
de l'invasion du 24 février mais depuis
deux mois il a récupéré cette valeur est
aujourd'hui la cua - 6 - 7 % de la verve
de la valeur qu'il avait juste avant le
24 février en attendant il ya quand même
de vrais effets sur l'économie russe a
très clairement aujourd'hui les russes
ont le sentiment d'avoir plutôt
circonscrit la problématique financière
mais évidemment concrètement pour le
peuple il est touché 17 pour son
inflation au mois de mars avec des
pointes à 19% pour tout ce qui est des
biens alimentaires un pib russe dont le
fmi nous dit qu'ils pourraient chuter en
négatif à -8 5% en 2022 des risques très
clairs de défaut de paiement sur la
dette de plus en plus fort bref
financièrement
la russie annonce qu'elle va pas pouvoir
tenir longtemps à partir de ses propres
réserves du coup sa stratégie puisqu'il
ya quand même 300 milliards de dollars
en dehors de la russie sa stratégie va
être de jouer la carte judiciaire de
porter plainte pour pouvoir avoir accès
à ces 300 milliards de dollars merci
beaucoup ali pour le